you shot in Venice you shot in London
what has it been like to be on this
world wind sort of summer vacation while
you're working around the world in
Europe it was kind of cool it was
interesting the day we walked on set for
the first time it felt like we'd come
back from our summer break it felt like
spider-man 1 was our first year of
school and this was our second year of
school yeah so didn't feel like any time
had really passed but for me like to be
able to bring spider-man the franchise
to my home city was really really
awesome and I'm super proud that I was
able to do that and then it's also have
my friends come and spend some time in
London and show them around the city was
really awesome and woody what do you do
what's your thing well you got up to
along they went to the Harry Potter
studio my birthday very upsetting
because the Harry Potter studios were
directly outside the studio where I was
working was literally all the same no
yeah so while they were having so much
fun I was being literally from where we
were
listen I I'm always so impressed with
all of you
how much you did in this film behind the
scenes footage of you and I mean you're
running and pull swinging and jumping
and all the stunts but then you're
getting kind of your butt kick the water
coming to you slamming into doors I mean
what is that like and you went into it
like okay I'm gonna do this absolutely I
mean when you get given an opportunity
like this you'd be a bit of an idiot if
you didn't go for it you know and for me
when it comes to doing the stunts I've
always been quite an athletic person and
I've always loved gymnastics so quite an
athletic person I'm a specimen for me
it's been really fun to be able to like
push myself to come to a new level with
the stunts and stuff and and you know
the pole running sequence in Venice the
big pole vault there's actually a bit
that's not in the film where we do it
it's called the tic-tac where I jump up
the wall that was really fun and it was
just it was a great time to spend you
know five or six weeks practicing those
stunts for the stunt crew and getting
them down what's it like for you guys to
on set and be like that's our friend and
it might be broken soon um honestly like
we're so used to him doing it know that
it's kind of like just part of it you
know yeah I just know that like for some
reason if he gets hit in the face or
something that's not as bad as I thought
it would be but it actually was pretty
bad why would it not be as bad as you
thought because on the first one it just
seemed like you I was invincible yeah
yeah yeah we were to be worried we
worried when you just like hang up there
for yeah I swear it's like one of the
Venice secrets when him and Betty are in
the boat and they get when they fly sure
I was nerve-racking because it was Jacob
and we need to protect Jake oh it wasn't
that bad you know I felt like a carnival
ride yeah and then you got to go on your
first Spidey web ride yeah how did you
prep her honestly anti-climatic it was
because I did a first version of that
we're like okay so we're gonna do is
we're gonna like drop you guys like 100
take you up 100 feet in there and I be
swing and that's the footage that we're
gonna use so we did that and didn't end
up using it it didn't work it didn't
work it didn't look as cool as we
thought it was gonna look even though we
did drop a hundred feet and we ended up
literally just like dangling like a foot
or two over it's poor low yeah with some
fans and just like it was just shake us
essentially it was funny when they were
like cinching us in they we were
attached together and then we attach to
the wires and I'm saying like it's
really fine it's gonna be good like you
know just hold on and we'll be a fun
ride and then they're taking us up on my
glass wow this is really high I'm really
stressed no I really don't like this as
far as we're going and Andrews breaking
the internet with her new hair color
there's many people talking about it
people say that the comic was the
inspiration for the quote on Instagram
was it yeah it was I was like
very intentional it was just kind of I
was like a tribute to these to the og
character I love this um Jake admitted
on daytime TV that he thought this
sexiest Avenger I'm sure you've seen
this at all time was you and we correct
and or we came to the conclusion that
the reason he said Chris Hemsworth was a
sympathy vote the secret emsworth's
incredibly ugly so he's just trying to
make Chris feel a bit better about him
so yes that's why he said that I would
love you to vote well I would the
sexiest Avenger
I'm not gonna vote okay I'm into that
what was it like to welcome Jake to this
cast it was pretty special I mean he was
a great guy and he's someone who I
really was decree he was a great guy he
he is a great guy and I've really looked
up to him but you know it was really
exciting to inspire to introduce him a
new character into the MCU and he is
fantastic in this movie and he's the
perfect kind of person to fill the void
of a mentor for Peter Parker and you
know and I couldn't be happier that is
Ryan Reynolds did you get to try on the
bobble hat oh no it's all fake the whole
time no Jake no because I saw his
Instagram he was eating breakfast in the
bubble hat or was he aim was he that
yeah okay
all right Jake in it now in every
interview is that when I wear the bubble
hat I'm like no you didn't secrets the
last thing is in our behind the scenes
footage that we got there's the most
amazing footage of you and if spider-man
taking a drink on set
oh is that in the barn gene you talked
about that how this actually it's going
through your eye yeah it's an
interesting contraption to say the least
basically my eyes in my mask they clip
off they come off because they're glass
and
see the suit is it's fabric they need to
clip in and what I can do is I can take
my left one out and there's a little
like thing I pull out and then I put a a
tube a squeezy tube down into my mouth
and then I can drink drink from a from a
bottle thanks so much I'm really
struggling that but what I found out now
is it happens video of you doing that oh
yeah that store there's just a little
kid behind it was watching him drink
from his eye like you're ruining what I
found out is if I push the mask forward
I can now squeeze like dumb and stuff oh
down the eyehole I can kind of get it
I've had KitKat in the soup now and get
it out we would probably just wait to
take off the circles but how or if I got
a cake count I swallow it
[Music]